with the run time that exceeds the four
hour mark zack snyder's justice league
differs wildly from the 2017 theatrical
version of justice league which was
comprised heavily of footage
and scenes that were either re-shot
added or re-written by avengers director
joss whedon
the 2017 cut was very different from
what snyder had originally intended the
film to be
and as a result many fans have taken to
regarding the snyder cut as the one and
only real version of the film
of course dc fans weren't the only ones
happy to see the release of zack
snyder's justice league
the fan campaign that ultimately led to
the completion of the snyder cut was
boosted over the years by comments from
several justice league stars who
expressed their desire to see the
original version of the film released
snyder himself also appears to be
visibly relieved and grateful to have
gotten the chance to return to the
project
even if it also marks the end of his
time in the dceu
once and for all it looks like it's not
just dc fans or members of the film's
creative team who were excited to see
the updated 4-hour marathon
we have to stand together
jeffrey dean morgan shared his reaction
to the film on twitter this past weekend
with the walking dead actor adding to
the growing pile of online praise for
the film by tweeting
hell yes snyder cut congratulations my
friend you did us proud
despite having no role in the film
itself morgan was one of several
notable celebrities who tweeted about it
last week avengers endgame directors
anthony and joe russo also publicly
tweeted their excitement
and support for the film ahead of its
premiere of course morgan himself does
have some connections to the dc
universe even if he has no role in the
actual film
the actor has a history with snyder
having appeared as the comedian in
snyder's 2009 film adaptation of
watchmen
morgan also had a small role as thomas
wayne the late father of ben
affleck's bruce wayne in 2016's batman
vs superman dawn of justice
right now the actor stars as negan on
amc's the walking dead and
isn't currently slated to appear in any
of snyder's upcoming films but it's
clear that he still feels a strong
connection to the filmmaker
morgan's reaction also comes at the same
time that many fans are still calling
for his presence in the dceu to be
revived in a future dc comics adaptation
jeffrey dean morgan's role in batman vs
superman dawn of justice was admittedly
brief
the actor only appeared as thomas wayne
in one of the film's opening flashback
scenes and he hasn't been seen again
in any other dc eu film but that hasn't
stopped dc comics fans from publicly
calling for morgan to be brought back as
thomas wayne in a solo flash film
specifically dc fans have been open
about their desire to see morgan's take
on thomas wayne return in a
possible adaptation of the flashpoint
storyline from the comics which saw the
flash arrive in an alternate reality
where thomas wayne became batman after
watching his son bruce die
unfortunately despite the overwhelming
fan support for morgan's dc eu return
it seems unlikely that the actor will be
reprising his role as thomas wayne
anytime soon instead michael keaton is
currently set to return as batman in
director andy muschetti's flash movie
while morgan's time in the dc eu appears
to be up
at least that's what the actor told
comicbook.com last year in response to
keaton's return
saying michael keaton swooped in and
took my gig nah
i think that's super cool ever since
zack snyder walked away my whole kind of
bit in that world has walked away with
him
however there's always a chat going on
so we'll see
in other words it looks like jeffrey
dean morgan's screen time in the dceu
may end up being confined to just a few
moments
however it's clear that he's not letting
that stop him from continuing to show
support for zack snyder's work
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc
extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one